Boris Johnson's call for a third general
election in five years was voted down
this week as his opponent sought to trap
him in office but without power until
after the next brexit delay at least and
to write a general election solves
nothing we now inhabit a multi-party
universe
when considering likely gains by the
Liberal Democrats the SNP in Scotland
the SDLP and the Alliance party in
Northern Ireland the praxic party in
England and Wales and thus later former
Tory MPs standing as moderate
independence in England a hung
parliament with the keys your brexit
remaining unresolved looks set to be the
only plausible outcome most of us don't
want Johnson or Corbin and when
remainders are counted alongside soft
brexit errs most of us don't want to
know dual brexit either it doesn't have
to be Sophie's Choice let's remember the
definition of insanity is keep doing the
same thing over again only a second
referendum can unite Parliament around a
single proposition to put this
never-ending brexit monster to bed let
the nation choose between Teresa Mays
deal or remain you made a very eloquent
eloquent and correct point in the
earlier conversation in that we need to
reign you see this now in so many
instances what I cannot work out about
folks like you who I respect enormously
you honestly think that a second
referendum whichever and whichever way
it goes it's let's say it goes this time
to be a remain vote probably again by a
very narrow margin although we might
refer to what Professor John Curtis says
about look you honestly think whichever
side loses this time we just melt away
well so I think it's the I'll tell you
what a general election won't achieve a
general election you must concede will
only return the same thing it did when
Theresa May called it we've been there
before gauging the mood from the radio
station that both you and I and I've
been on the last couple of days there is
as Carol touched on there is an
extraordinary anger and I think people
like Dominic grieve who by the way I
think it's always interesting to be
lectured but I don't want to agree via
for me attorney
about loyalty in others because he's
ignored a no-confidence vote that he
lost in his own constituency and he
continues in poser
I always enjoy being lectured by people
such as that folks such as grieve and
others it will be a very different
looking house you said you just said let
the nation choose Boris Johnson has
offered people an opportunity to let the
nation choose an election they've said
no to your leader
and the Labor Party have been asking
have been asking for an election on a
weekly basis it has been Corbin's mantra
this country needs an election he was
even he was even where is he this week
he was somewhere in Salford this and he
said to people we will fight and we will
win an election suddenly now he's been
offered one on a plate this was his
chance to show his mettle that he's some
kind of Boris Johnson running scared so
remaining opposition parties want an
election and they are unanimous in
agreeing that Boris Johnson cannot be
trusted to hold one in good faith well
you always forget you know Nick I agree
I don't think a second referendum is a
great option there are no good options
the reason I agree with Majid and I
think it is the only option is that the
No Deal breaks that we're talking about
is also not a solution it doesn't give
us anything it gives us now years and
years of negotiation of uncertainty
nobody knows what the outcomes are No
Deal breaks it would be it's just
proceeding with no Australia I've said
we'll have one example of where a nation
has managed to conclude suggested to
Donald Trump that a year was two before
I let Rachel now I just want to just on
a point of information the reason the
opposition rejected Boris Johnson's
offer for a general election just to
give their interpretation on this is
because actually if he had suspended
Parliament before this bill was passed
this bill that prevents no deal then
that bill ceases to become more if
Parliament is suspended before it's
approved in the House of Lords and so
to support a general election and if
you'd call that then that that bill base
is that we will not a jump to Boris
Johnson stood he's offered them what
they've been asking just mentioned him
this is the shadow breaks at secretary
care so on that point I think in the end
the only way out of this is to say to
the public look here's the deal if there
is a Deanna Thompson deal I'm not sort
of will be or no deal
do you want that do you really want that
or would you not rather remain because
we've got to have either permission to
go on those bases or or the protection
of remaining yes I think that's the only
way to break this impasse now I know
Rachel's desperate to get in but also
just to back up the point let's have a
look at how many people in the public
wants a general election there you go
you see only 35 percent support it was
46 percent opposed the idea everybody is
really tired everybody's tired of
politics of brexit of elections and a
referendum everybody's sick of it but
the thing about the thing about having a
general election is that we need that
kind of reset one of the things about
BRICS and one of the things that Labor
Party and other opposition parties say
is that it's not just about BRICS it's
about the causes of brexit it's all well
and good to say well we need to have a
referendum to decide what actually
people want three years later but the
fact of the matter is first of all
there's no there's no majority for that
in in Parliament but secondly that won't
actually address a much bigger malaise
that we've got in this society brexit is
one big part of the election labor very
simply don't want an election because
they know they will lose 23 seats
you want those campaigning for leave
would most likely include Boris Johnson
and Nigel Faraj no suspend your personal
feelings they are the two probably most
potent politicians that you can possibly
imagine
they'll be batting for leave I think
Nigel probably is more so okay but
you'll allow right who's gonna open the
batting for the remain site well that's
a good question and the remains what I
would say is that actually when if the
nation were to be presented this choice
then I think the phenomenon of remain is
large enough at this stage not to
necessarily need a prominent award it's
Boris Johnson's government they have so
shown their incompetence their
selfishness and their dishonesty I
honestly think people have been watching
and thinking if this is our future out
of Europe gonna win by a landslide when
he goes because the brexit party will
shave off certain votes from the right
and he's gonna need a pact with them
which will mean he loses seats to them
if he does that that pact the Lib Dems
will take votes from his left and that
means he's squeezed on both ends and
then of course don't forget then you've
got other parties rising such as the SNP
I'm not so sure you'll have a majority
in parliament might win in percentage if
there was a second referendum and and
leave one by a margin again do we think
that all the people know all the
remainders now are suddenly gonna have a
Damascene conversion state all this time
I will respect the Parliament winning by
a landslide really weird I mean I think
you know there is it there is a
constituency of this country that likes
the sort of authoritarianism hard right
politics that he presents is small and
receding and if you look at the polling
on other issues aside from bricks it's
quite clear that there is majority
support for the kind of progressive
politics but progressive parties are
here's one vote that I'm taking which is
it is time to move on